[Music]
this is the grill for you I call it the
Obama come on say amaz my Elmo the pig
boy I call this the big black machine oh
my god do you smell gas a little bit
came out but how's the nervous that's
just a quick you're the best salesman
I've ever seen I can see you being a
stockbroker like me could you give me a
job I wish I could my boss won't let me
hire out that Burger he dropped out of
Harvard you dropped down a Piedmont high
that was a couple credits shy of
graduating I got to get my GED I'm the
principal of this school I can do
whatever I want
yo ran my house are you using a blank
voice no I don't hear color alright
let's do some introductions my name is
Carrie I'm here to make a little extra
cash so that I can afford this one that
I got but that's none of our business
welcome to nice girl this book is kind
of thick I thought it'd be more like a
leaflet it's not gonna do the work drop
the class no I'm gonna do the work
you'll see we'll see
yes we will great superb excellent good
[Music]
you're gonna be a financial analyst I am
and it starts immediately I've been
waiting on the Lord to bring me a
pint-sized little man who can fill this
out let me get you chicken from the Lord
you take that test I tend to wash away
thank you
are you trying to get y'all TV are you
trying to get your GED
yes you can get out my way be
we're correct oh you're clinically down
there is no cure for what you have oh my
god
I got learning herpes I got to give the
people give it boy you did the black
waist thing we have it's not a black
voice not a black voice you don't
remember when you was in that meeting he
was like we gonna get it lit up and hear
this meeting lit it was very lit I keep
it 100 when have I ever not kept it 100
[Music]